les kayaks sont déjà de sortie mais peu
de kayakistes en vue sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
nathan le soleil mais les activités ne
manqueront pas cet été au programme mini
golf balades énigmes quad karting ou
encore parcours acrobatiques pour cette
saison cette activité purement estivale
a été agrandi un parcours supplémentaire
et puis le doublement du parcours le
plus difficile en fait le parcours noir
donc voilà l'objectif étant d'apporter
plus de fluidité à la pratique ça c'est
vraiment la grosse nouveauté pour autant
les contraintes et sanitaires ne sont
jamais loin la dissociation cela dans
toutes les activités c'est quelque chose
qui est prise en compte et le port du
masque un certain moment même sur les
activités en extérieur exemple aux
parcours acrobatiques en hauteur quand
il faut s'équiper
lassé masque obligatoire à partir de 5
ans des temps forts viendront ponctuer
l'été comme le village sportif et
culturel à destination des jeunes et des
familles le judo tour donnera des
initiations gratuites et un cinéma de
plein air sera mise en place en fonction
des événements les jauges seront seront
différentes sur le village sportif et
culturel
on a à z des ateliers avec 12 personnes
maximum sur 4 ha donc on aura 150
personnes au maximum sur l'eau sur
l'espace même protocole du côté des
étangs de hollande
depuis le 1er juillet la jauge est passé
à 1000 personnes sur place mais les
contraintes sanitaires tendent à
s'assouplir
après lyon est moins de gestes barrières
effectivement je vérifie parce qu'à
chaque fois vous savez c est un peu mou
vent ça peut changer à la dernière
minute donc oui effectivement un
allègement général des mesures tout en
étant restant précautionneux les
visiteurs pourront donc apprécier la
baignade et le bronzage mais aussi des
activités comme le pédalo le mini golf
ou encore le kayak la base de loisirs
est un élément majeur d'attractivité du
territoire sur l'aspect bien sûr sports
loisirs mais aussi tourisme c'est un
site absolument remarquable qui est un
atout pour pour le sud yvelines sur une
saison de mai à septembre sans qu'ovide
50000 visiteurs étaient présents sur le
site
les responsables espèrent se rapprocher
de ce nombre cette année si les
conditions sanitaires le permettent